في الملف الاوكراني لا صوت يعلو فوق معركه
سوليدار المتنازع عليها بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه في ظل سعي موسكو الى
تحقيق اول انتصار كبير لها في الشرق كيف
اكدت ان القوات الاوكرانيه تواجه موجات من
هجمات القوات الروسيه على بلده سوليدار
الصغيره الغنيه بالمنام فيما قالت مخابرات
غربيه ان القوات الروسيه ومجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه سيطرت بالفعل على البلده
وان هدفها القادم
سيطره القوات الروسيه على سوليدار
الافضليه في ظل قتلها لسيطره على مدينه
محمود على بعد عده كيلومترات الى الجنوب
الغربي المخابرات البريطانيه رشحت ان
روسيا من خلال محورها في سوريا دار تسعى
الى تطبيق من الشمال وتعطيل خطوط التواصل
الاوكرانيه وهو ما رصده مراسل على الارض
رئد الاخبار
ما زال جيش الروسي يحاصر او يطوق مدينه
باخمط من الناحيه الجنوبيه والشرقيه
وتطوق قوات فاجنر والقوات الشيشانيه كما
هي قوات لوغانسكي الشعبيه بلده سيلدار
المتاخمه لباخ مت من الناحيه الشماليه
وتدور هناك معارك ضاريه يعني معارك وحروب
في الشوارع قتال شوارع اذا صح التعبير بين
هذه القوات الخاصه والجيش الاوكراني الذي
ما زال صامدا ويحاول جيش الروسي دفعه
للانسحاب من الناحيه الغربيه
الاله العسكريه الروسيه اا الثقيله تقصف
باستمرار المناطق الغربيه والطريق السريع
الذي يوصل امدادات عسكريه وبشريه الى
القوات المحاصره لذلك لا امدادات لهذه
القوات المحاصره بينما ما زالت القوات
الروسيه تقصف مناطق عديده منها نقطه اتصال
عبر
سبوتنيكسار لي حيث قطع الاتصال ما بين
القياده والمقاتلين على الجبهات
وفي ظل تسارع التقدم الروسي في الشرق
الاكرانيه يبقى الحل في الدعم الغربي
بالاسلحه لاوكرانيا بالتحديد انظمه الدفاع
الجوي لمواجهه الهجمات الروسيه المكثفه
بالمسيرات والتي تعتبر رخيصه الثمن نسبه
لانظمه مواجهتها صحيفه ولطي جورنال نقلت
عن ممثلين عن اداره الرئيس ان البنتاجون
يواجهوا صعوبات في تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه
استطلاع وضرب نموذجيه للتصدي للمسيرات من
طراز باير الصحيفه في تقريرها اوضحت ان
حجمه العقد لتوريد المنظومات يبلغ حوالي
40 مليون دولار وهو ما لا يكفي للكميات
الكبيره التي تطلبها كافت بحسب التقرير
فان الولايات المتحده ستسلم اربع مجمعات
من باير الى اوكرانيا في موعد لا يتجاوز
منتصف هذا العام كما ذكر ان 10 انظمه اخرى
ستكون في نفس النوع من نفس الن تحت تصرف
كياب بحلول نهايه العام الحالي
الحليف البريطاني دائما ما كان جاهزا
بالمعلومات الاستخباراتيه تدريب الجنود
وايضا الاسلحه يا طاهر هذه المره حاولت
لندن دفع الحلفاء الى تغيير طريقه هذا
الدم